my next guest is an expert on drinking
water and he's created
a 40-page water menu at
ray's and stark bar right here in los
angeles please welcome
the country's first water sommelier
martin riza
okay martin i heard about you and i was
fascinated you are a water sommelier
correct and you believe uh that there
are many types of water and flavors of
water and that it's important to know
the distinction
i'm not even believing in that i think
there is actually it's a it's a fact you
devoted your life to this
yes yes okay so you must believe this uh
you have a degree for this is that
correct correct in 2010 i received my
certification as a
mineral water summary from the german
water association
okay so you are certified as a water
sommelier correct
all right you uh have a menu here 20
types of water
at raisin stock bar and i was flipping
through this and it's all these waters
now don't they all just taste
like water i hate to sound ignorant but
doesn't it just taste like water
uh yes and no so they're all definitely
water so they're all coming from the
same like source because
up from there because it's all rainbow
at one point yes and they're dripping
down raining down
of the different like salts and
different layers of the grounds and the
water going through different layers
the same like wine kind of and they
suddenly they're taking minerals with
them and so they taste differently and
you can say like okay this water comes
from spain it tastes like
a little bit more like salty and bitter
then maybe a water comes from the future
islands
yes okay so you can actually do that you
can taste
water and say yes yes yes i'm getting
hints of what what are you getting hints
of
some saltiness bitterness i'm getting
slated i'm getting
granite i'm getting so i'm getting some
mud what am i getting here actually i
have one water with me today what we
want to try it's like a little
earthy notes to it as well it has an
earthiness all right i find this
fascinating
when did you first notice that you were
fascinated by water i think my parents
noticed that first
because i'm coming from the danish
border so up north from germany
and when i went on vacation with my
parents the first thing what i always
did in different cities
i was drinking tap water and my parents
was like whoa what's going on with our
son why is he so thirsty
for me it was more like it's a taste
numb
it's the taste that you don't get it and
they're like it's water what's wrong we
should see a doctor maybe or something
yes yes
yes maybe you should see a doctor yes so
so you would you were constantly
drinking water but it was just because
you
you could taste different flavors and
clearly your parents couldn't right they
just were like it's water
now they can because now i explain them
a little bit as well and i think
everybody can do it and i think even the
whole audience will
can can do it as well when they're
coming to raise in stock and they will
see like how
water can actually taste different all
right we're going to do a tasting now
and we're going to bring out uh some
different kinds of waters they're going
to be brought out right now
i know that's going to happen and it's
going to happen soon and here it comes
and uh you're going to take us through
you have brought a lot of these waters
is that right these are your waters yeah
thank you john is in my waters but like
i didn't mean this came from your body
this water was slowly slowly leached
from your body
through your pores um tell us how do you
even do a water tasting
help me it's almost like the same with
wine and therefore we brought some wine
glasses
and so the great thing about our water
tasting so
all we can like after our water tasting
go straight to like
being pulled over by the police and we
don't have to worry that's the greatest
thing actually about the water tasting
yes what if we've murdered somebody yeah
yeah that's a good question someone
wants to know what if you've murdered
someone yeah that'd be tricky
then you've got a different problem all
right okay so
all right why don't you get us started
let's do this um so i brought like some
kind of variety
and yes all the varieties of water are
right before us
but because we're saying like um h2o is
like the sharma correction of water
so it's all h2o but they all have
different
tds levels and tds level mean
total dissolved solids so that's really
depends like
what water tastes like maybe fruity
maybe salty maybe bitter
and we're starting here with burke it's
a canadian ice glacier water 15 000
years old water this is 15
000 year old water yep and this this
must be very expensive hopefully it
tastes like water
okay and what do i do right here so it
is pretty expensive
all right and what can i do to taste
this water take me through it drink it
okay
am i supposed to sniff it first no my
grandmother always saying matcha when
you like
when you like have a like a small like
order or something on your water don't
drink it
okay so so if it's odorless you know
you've got good water correct
oh here we go
it's water great it's water i love it
it's water no but yeah and okay no it's
super clean super
it's like super smooth i would say as
well on your palette there's like no
saltiness no
what are you what are you getting simon
what are you what are you getting
i'm getting uh disappointment
okay so i need to contrast this we need
to contrast this time and that's what we
need to do
so i set this a little bit i gotta sign
again
here we go that's for you and this is
for me now this is a little sparkly yes
i'm getting sparkles getting some
bubbles
no odor
and that just that actually tastes like
it has a lot of salt in it correct
thank you so this has a tedious level of
3500.
i don't like this at all this is like
this is like salt water
this is salt water that is salty this is
what you drink when you're dying on a
raft
it tastes like what i'm always saying it
tastes like two aspirins already
absorbed in that water exactly it tastes
like alka seltzer yeah perfect yeah it's
a perfect water for you the hangover
water
yeah thank you thank you for calling our
first guest a drunk
peter that's a great job now i'm going
to eat some crackers in between
oh my gosh when you do a wine taste you
put some crackers in between
yeah maybe what are you talking about
so you don't cleanse the power i don't
cleanse my pelvis because yeah you don't
want to cleanse your palate with water
or water so
um you want to actually see the
difference in water so you don't
you should not abstract your palate with
different like taste
like with crackers or something actually
the wine tasting i'm gonna actually have
wine in between i love
that
in fact if we could just switch over to
wine that would be fantastic all right
what's the next water because we're
almost out of time actually get a
perfect
water for your wine yeah great okay so
you're gonna pair a water with my wine
correct and this water can actually does
that this is beverly hills 9 or h2o
you're going to prison for that we got a
special number for you
1 12. i heard something is special about
the state 112.
oh you're looking at me
okay so this is the is this like a
really good water right here yes
okay so this is the one that is water
comes from the sun of ida mountains
and we add different minerals to it to
pair perfectly
with great wines like what do you have
right there okay
never been done before and they are all
limited edition so this is number
112 of ten thousand
and this water is like super smooth
crisp
and it changed your wine i'm getting and
this tastes exactly like the first water
we had
to me what do you mean no yes okay taste
your first one you can't tell me what i
feel where's the first one
how do i know what the first one is
i can make both glasses
salty one
okay this is the first one
[Laughter]
no i don't get anything
what do you taste do you taste anything
simon well my wife swears that uh evian
is grittier than volvic she said that to
me once it's
it no it's gritty i said why can't we
have vivian she should know it's gritty
i want volvik
so she can tell and she's just a
layperson
you're not like that i didn't mean that
well i guess for me it's actually the
most important thing
i'm getting jealous now here it's like
that that's mine too
you want why don't you stick to your
party pal
okay yeah there you go it's fun
there you go yay
you say tomato i say tomato
oh that's good i'm glad that you're
saying like okay this witchy color is
super salty
and matchy would go into a restaurant
and they're just having one brand
okay and might be it's that what you
want to do your dream is to train people
to be disappointed by the kind of water
they're getting in a restaurant
no i believe like an options there's a
bug flying around
this bug is trying to end this segment
hey listen uh that is all the time we
have for you but martin you know what i
do i respect your passion i respect your
passion
i don't see the difference myself but i
know it's there at least you saw it by
one water
what's that at least you're sold by this
one yeah the one you threw aspirin in